HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON: Thank
you, everybody, for coming.
I am Heidi Grant Halvorson.
I'm the Associate Director
of the Motivation Science
Center at Columbia University.
But I'm actually not here to
talk to you about motivation.
Today, I'm here to talk about
an even more universal problem.
And that is the problem
of coming across the way
you intend to with other people.
I mean, probably
everyone in this room
knows what it feels like
to feel misunderstood.
You may suspect that some
of the people around you
don't quite get you.
You are right to suspect
this, because it's
almost certainly the case.
One of the things social
psychologists have learned
in about four decades now
of studying how we all
make sense of one another
is that there's more often
than not a really
large gap between how
we think we're coming
across to other people
and how we actually are.
In fact, if you look at
studies of first-year college
students, roommates
who are being paired up
for the first time, and you
ask one of the roommates
to fill out a questionnaire
about their personality traits
and then you ask the other
roommates to fill out
a questionnaire about the
first roommate's traits,
what you find is that
three to four months
into living together, the
correlation between those two
things is zero.
There is literally
no relationship
between how one
roommate sees themselves
and how the other
roommate sees them.
It takes almost the entire
first year of living together
for those two things to
even begin to sync up,
and then it gets
to be about 0.2.
It's true that the more you
know someone, the more likely
they are to be accurate
about you, the more likely
they are to perceive
you correctly.
But even when you
look at people who
have been in relationships for
years, intimate relationships,
who've known every
part of one another,
and you look at the
correlations that they
have in their
perceptions, you find
they get to about 0.5 or
0.6-- so not 0, which is good.
But not 1, either.
Right.
There's still a lot of room
for misunderstandings to occur.
And they happen all the time.
And sometimes, when
we fail to come
across the way we
intend to, there
are some pretty
serious consequences.
Does anybody know who this is?
AUDIENCE: Is it Chip
Wilson, the Lululemon CEO?
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON:
Chip Wilson, yes.
Oh, bonus points-- she
gets a free book, if she
doesn't have one already.
That is Chip Wilson.
He was the founder and chairman
and CEO of Lululemon Athletica.
They make very, very,
very expensive yoga pants.
[LAUGHTER]
And they have a very
devout following,
or at least they did up
until a few years ago
when they kind of hit a little
bit of a bump in the road.
They had come up with a
new line of yoga pants
using a new fabric,
and the customers
found that over time, they were
pilling in between the thighs.
So pilling, for those
of you who don't know,
is when fabric
rubs against itself
and makes those little balls
that are really annoying.
So customers complained
about the pilling
in their very, very
expensive yoga pants.
And instead of doing what he
probably should have done,
which was apologize, say that
he was going to make it right,
say that he was going to
fix the fabric situation,
he went on Bloomberg TV
and said the following.
"Some women's bodies are just
not right for our pants,"
which turned out to have
been the wrong thing to say.
It was interpreted by many, many
of Lululemon's loyal customer
base as basically the
equivalent of saying,
if your fat thighs are ruining
your expensive yoga pants,
that's your problem
and not mine.
And so he actually is no
longer the chairman and CEO
of Lululemon Athletica, largely
because of this specific moment
that he just never was really
able to climb back from.
What's interesting--
if you watch the video,
you'll see that he has no
idea he said anything wrong.
He has no idea he said anything
even vaguely offensive.
But do you know who knew
immediately that he had?
His wife.
So that's Shannon Wilson.
She is one of the chief
designers of Lululemon.
And she was all smiles
in the interview,
literally right up until
this moment where he says,
some women's bodies are
not right for our pants.
And she looked at him
like that, and she
knew-- so big, big problem.
Again, is this what he intended?
I mean, did he literally intend
to insult half of his customer
base?
No, obviously not.
But because he came across in
a way that he didn't intend,
his career suffered
tremendously.
I want to show you one more.
And I apologize in advance
for the quality of this image.
I have scoured the internet
and cannot find another version
of this, but I love
this story so much.
I'm going to tell you anyway.
Here's another great
example of someone
coming across in a way
they did not intend.
That is former President
George W. Bush at a G8 summit.
The woman in yellow is
Angela Merkel of Germany.
Now, I haven't
been to one, but I
imagine that G8 summits are kind
of tense-- very stressful, lots
of issues being grappled with.
And evidently, he
thought so too,
and thought that Angela
Merkel could use a back rub.
And so I just want to
show you the play by play
of how this actually went.
If you look on the
far left, you can
see he's actually sort of
doing the approach here.
And then if you
focus here, you can
see this seems to be the
moment where she realizes
she's being rubbed and is
beginning to sort of grimace,
and then here is the moment
where she actually physically
shakes him off of her,
because apparently,
don't touch Angela Merkel is
something some people need
to be told explicitly.
Most of us just
would intuit that.
So here he is, and he
runs away afterward.
The German press went crazy.
They thought it was
incredibly offensive.
They thought it was patronizing,
and they thought it was sexist.
There is no video of him
attempting to give Vladimir
Putin a back rub, right?
It's the only woman in the
room that gets the rub.
Again, though, not my
favorite president admittedly,
but I feel a little
bad when I see this,
because I think in
fairness, the guy
was probably just trying
to be nice, right?
He was trying to
do something nice.
It was wildly
inappropriate, but he was
trying to do something nice.
And the question is, why
don't people get that?
Why don't they get that he
didn't really mean any harm?
In general, the reason
why people don't get us
as much as we think they should
and as much as we think they do
is that each of us is
much harder to understand
than we actually realize.
There is something called
the illusion of transparency
that we all sort
of buy into, which
is that we think we're all open
books to a much larger extent
than we actually are.
We assume that our thoughts
and beliefs and intentions
are obvious, when that could
not be further from the truth.
And just to kind of give
you a sense of why that's
the case, let's look at
the information you have
to try to understand yourself
versus the information
other people have to
try to understand you.
OK?
So let's see, your intentions--
yes, you know what they are.
No, other people do not.
You could tell
them, but we don't.
Generally speaking,
we do not tell
people what our intentions are.
We just assume that they know.
Thoughts-- same thing.
You know what you're thinking.
Other people don't.
Your feelings-- yes, you
know what you're feeling.
Other people don't.
But, you say, what about
your facial expressions?
Can't I tell what you're
feeling just by looking at you?
Not exactly.
And that's because
there's a little bit
of a problem with that one.
Yes, other people are
looking at your face
to try to figure out
what you're feeling.
But you don't know what
you're doing with your face,
and sometimes there are
very big disconnects there.
My editor at Harvard
Business Review
a few years ago
had joined there,
and kind of came in to manage
an already functioning team.
And it was really
important to him
that everyone there
know immediately that he
valued their opinion,
he was really interested
in their input.
So he said-- he
immediately made an effort
in those first
meetings with his team
to wear his active
listening face.
And it took about
six weeks for someone
on the team to say,
Tim, why are you
always so angry in meetings?
And he said, no no, that's
my active listening face.
And it turns out, his
active listening face
was just really furious looking.
So often, we don't know what
we're doing with our faces
and we're sending the
wrong signals with them.
Same thing with
body language-- yes,
absolutely, other people
are using your body language
to figure things out about
you, largely unconsciously.
But most of us
actually have no idea
what we're doing with our
bodies most of the time.
You can cultivate
awareness of your body,
but there's this great-- in
Sir Ken Robinson's Ted Talk,
the one that's, I think,
still the most popular one
of all time, he
has this great joke
about how academics treat their
bodies as if they exist only
to take their heads to meetings.
And I love that
joke, but I think
it's actually true of
everybody, not just academics.
Most of us are not paying
attention to our bodies
most of the time.
But other people are.
And again, how you're sitting,
how you hold yourself,
can really send a lot of
signals you don't mean to send.
OK, so what about these
last two, your behavior
and what you say?
I mean, this one, you'd
feel like, OK, yes, I
know what I do and say,
and other people also
know what I do and say, right?
So they should be able to
use that to understand me.
But there's an asterisk there
for a couple of reasons.
One is that other people are
really not paying attention
to everything you do and say.
And in fairness, you're
not also paying attention
to what they do and say, right?
We often feel like everybody's
eyes are on us in ways
that they are not.
People have other stuff to do.
They're not necessarily hanging
on your every word or noticing
everything you do,
and because of that,
not everything you do
and say actually gets in
and is used then to process
their perception of you.
But there's an even
bigger problem, actually.
You know this expression, right?
Beauty is in the eye of the
beholder, or the perceiver.
It's perfectly true.
So is everything else.
So literally, everything
is a matter of perception--
not just beauty.
We tend to assume that is
sort of the relationship
between our words and
actions and how people see us
as a sort of one to one thing.
I do x, and therefore
they think x.
But that's not how it works.
I do x, and then that
x gets interpreted,
and then that's how they see me.
And everything we do is
open to interpretation, even
really simple stuff--
that you would
think if I said,
hey, how you doing,
that's unambiguous, right?
But is it, really?
What if I said, [MONOTONE VOICE]
hey, how you doing?
If there's a tone
there now suddenly,
are you annoyed with me?
What is that about?
So everything, right?
It's possible to sort of
read different things into.
So if we want to
try to figure out
how to come across
the way we intend,
we need to know what's happening
in the interpretation box.
And the answer is there's a
whole bunch of stuff that's
happening in the
interpretation box.
So what goes in there?
What goes in is
what you do and say.
And then things like
stereotypes and assumptions
that people make, almost
entirely unconsciously.
One of the scariest-- I mean,
most fascinating and most
terrifying-- findings in social
psychology in the last 30 years
is the realization
that you don't
need to believe a stereotype
in order to have it affect you.
You just need to know it.
And if you belong to
a particular culture,
you know all the stereotypes.
And stereotypes tend
to get activated
upon meeting a member
of a stereotyped group.
So that gets activated in
the brain of your perceiver.
It's in there.
It's in there with a whole
bunch of other stuff.
But there's always a chance
that stereotypes can influence
how people see you, even
when they don't believe
those stereotypes are true.
There are also a whole host
of assumptions most of us
run around having
no idea we're even
making about the other people
when we're perceiving them.
I'll give you one example,
because it's kind of hilarious,
that I particularly love.
It's an assumption that we
all make about one another.
It's called the false
uniqueness effect.
So there's really two of these.
There's false consensus,
which you may have heard of,
and false uniqueness.
False consensus is when we tend
to assume that other people
share our opinions.
So people who like
chocolate ice cream best,
if you ask them how many other
people like chocolate ice
cream best, they assume way more
people like chocolate ice cream
than they actually do.
We all tend to think our
opinions are right, OK?
So that's false consensus.
False uniqueness,
however, is that we all
tend to think we're better
people than everyone else,
that our good qualities are more
unique than they actually are.
And my favorite
version of this of time
comes from a study that
was done in the 1980s.
It was actually a phone
survey of Americans.
And they asked
people two questions.
For each of the Ten
Commandments, do you obey it?
And then, what percentage
of other Americans
do you think obey this
commandment as well?
So here's what they found.
I want to just
highlight one thing.
I don't know about
you-- I thought
that number would be higher.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a phone survey, right?
People are like,
yeah, no, sorry.
I break that one all
the time, on the phone.
Which is fine.
But you can see
in general, people
are claiming at least that
they follow, for the most part,
most of the Ten Commandments.
But here's the percentage
of other Americans
they think are doing it.
So then you see the giant drop.
So apparently, most people
think that only 71% of us
are not killing people.
It's amazing anyone
actually leaves their house
if they're under
that impression.
Yeah, not killing people is
not that special apparently.
So anyway, this is
the kind of thing
that does seep into, once
again, our perceptions of one
another-- that there's a
tendency for us to think
that other people probably are
not as morally and ethically
good, or as capable
or as smart as we are.
What else goes into the box?
Past experience with
you goes into the box.
And that's a good thing, right?
You want people to use their
past experience with you
to try to understand
your behavior today.
So if you make a joke and it's
in a little bit bad taste,
but I know you and I know
that you're a funny person
and you're generally
kind-hearted,
then I'm more likely to
interpret that in a benign way
and not get offended by it.
And that's the kind of thing
we want people to do, right?
We want them to use
their history with us
to understand what we do
today-- unless, of course,
your history with
someone is actually not
representative of what
they're actually like.
This is the whole
power-of-first-impressions
thing.
Once you make a first
impression on someone,
then they're going to use
that to interpret everything
you do afterward.
And I'll show you one
scary example of this.
This was a study
that was done where
math teachers, elementary
school math teachers,
were watching two children
perform a math test.
And the math test
had 30 questions.
And this was their
performance on the first 15.
So in the first 15, Tim
gets 11 of them right
and Charlotte gets four right.
But then on the second half,
Tim only gets four right
and Charlotte gets 11.
So if you look at their
total performance,
it's exactly the same.
Guess which kid all the teachers
think is better at math.
Go ahead, guess.
AUDIENCE: Tim.
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON: It's Tim.
And it's not because
Tim is a boy,
because you can run these
with the same gender.
It doesn't matter.
It's entirely a
primacy effect, right?
It's entirely that what
they learned first about Tim
was that he seemed to
be very good at math.
And what they learned
first about Charlotte
was that she didn't
seem to be, and they
didn't correct
sufficiently afterward
for the changes in
their performance.
So obviously, this is scary,
to think that perception works
this way, that people
who are late bloomers
or who maybe don't make
a good first impression,
are going to have that
following them around
and have everything they
do seen through that lens.
I mean, I'd love to
be the person that
got up here and
said, everything you
hear about first
impressions being important
is not such a big deal.
It is.
It really is.
It takes a lot of work to
undo a bad first impression.
It's completely
doable, but it takes
hundreds of times
the amount of work
to undo a bad one
than it does to make
a good one in the first place.
And we'll talk more about
how to make a good one
in the first place in a minute.
So that goes in there.
What else goes in there?
Stuff about them, right?
Their perception of you is
affected by stuff about them--
their experiences, their
goals, their motivations,
their beliefs, things that have
nothing to do with you at all.
I saw a very scary
statistic the other day,
that one study had shown
performance review ratings,
that about over 60% of the
variability in performance
review ratings is
attributed to the rater,
not the person being rated--
not your performance,
but the person who's actually
rating your performance.
Over half of the variability
in that is actually
the person doing the rating.
OK?
OK, that's depressing.
Let's just move on to the
next thing, which is context.
Context goes into
the box, as well.
And that's a good thing.
You want context.
You want people to take
the situation into account.
So if I'm a little bit
cranky with you one day
but you know that I'm
under a lot of pressure
and I haven't slept
well, I want you
to take that
context into account
when you interpret
my behavior, and not
just think that I'm a jerk.
So that's great.
We want context.
Context helps people to
be accurate about you.
Here's the problem.
Every single thing I mentioned
up until this one is automatic.
So it's just an automatic
part of perception--
that we use stereotypes
and assumptions,
we use past experience
with you, stuff about me
gets into it when I'm
trying to understand you.
But context takes effort,
and it takes mental capacity.
So when people are not motivated
to be accurate about you
or when they're too cognitively
busy to really spend
the time thinking
about it, they're
not going to take
context into account.
OK, so now it's really
depressing, right?
Because now you're seeing all
this stuff and you think, OK,
how is it possible we ever
understand each other at all,
honestly, because
all of this stuff
is getting in the way
of any of us being
accurate about one another?
And the answer is that--
well, the good news really,
is that there are certain kinds
of signals that you can send
that are clearer than others.
You can kind of think of
this whole perception issue
as trying to send a
really good signal
amongst a whole lot of noise.
And certain kinds of
behaviors and kinds
of things you can say
reliably are interpreted
in a particular
way by other people
and can help you then to
make the impression you're
trying to make, or to come
across the way you're intending
to with people, whether
your work colleagues
or in your personal life.
And so I want to take the time
that I have left to give you
what some of those signals are.
These are actually useful things
that, if you do more of them,
you'll come across
more the way you
intend to in more situations.
First, we're going to
talk about the signals
that you need to send in order
to be trusted by other people.
This is particularly
important if you're
in a leadership position.
But honestly, it's important
in all relationships
to be trusted.
And then, the signals you need
to send to be likable-- now,
that last one has obviously
got a lot of components to it.
But there are certain
issues that really come up
a lot when it comes to how to be
likeable with your colleagues.
So I want to talk
about some signals
to send to make sure that
your colleagues like you as
much as you would like them to.
OK, so let's start with trust.
Fun fact-- so our
brains are basically
hunter-gatherer brains.
10,000 years ago,
life for humans
looked very, very different.
But our brains have
not changed at all.
So we have the same wiring.
And that wiring
made a lot of sense
when we were
hunter-gatherers, and it
complicates things a little
bit now in our modern world
sometimes.
But one of the
things you have to do
when you are a
hunter-gatherer-- actually,
the thing you have to do when
you're a hunger-gatherer--
was stay alive.
It was sort of job one, all
day every day, to not die.
And in order to not die, you
need to very, very quickly
be able to assess whether or not
another human or creature was
a friend or a foe,
was somebody who
was going to help
you and support you
or somebody who was going
to hit you with a big stick.
And you needed to know
that pretty much as
fast as possible.
So our brains are wired
to ask this question.
We ask it whenever
we meet someone new,
but we actually continue to ask
it throughout our relationships
with people-- again, on a
largely unconscious level,
we're processing this question.
Can I trust you?
Are you my friend or foe?
And it turns out that the
way we calculate the answer
to that question basically
has to do with your ability
to project two qualities.
These are the two qualities that
make you trustworthy-seeming.
I mean, it's great to
be actually trustworthy,
and you should do that, too.
But if you're
actually trustworthy
and you don't projects
trustworthiness,
it just doesn't help you.
So here's how you
project trustworthiness,
through projecting both
warmth and competence.
Warmth sends the message
to the other person
that you're on their side.
You have good
intentions toward them.
Competent signals
send the message
that you can act on those
intentions if you choose to.
So warm and competent people
are very powerful allies,
and cold and competent people
are very potent enemies.
And you can illustrate
this really nicely,
as you can I think literally
every concept in psychology,
with "The Simpsons."
So if you're wandering
around Springfield
and you need some
help, who do you go to?
You go to Lisa Simpson.
She's warm and competent, right?
She's wicked smart,
but she's also
somebody who you know would have
good intentions towards you,
and she's all kinds
of nice and pleasant.
So that's the person
you would go to.
Unfortunately,
here's the problem.
People are very good-- I'm
sure everybody in this room
is actually very good at sending
signals of competence, right?
We know intuitively how to
do that, and we learn it,
and we're aware of it.
We're aware that we need
to appear competent.
Most people are not aware
that they need to appear warm,
and they're very bad
at intuiting what they
need to do in order to do that.
If you fail to send
warmth signals,
then there is no happy
medium ground here.
If you fail to send
warmth signals,
you will come across as cold.
And then you're Mr. Burns.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's it.
You're either Lisa or
you're Mr. Burns, right?
You're very competent, but
definitely not on your side.
And this is a mistake actually
leaders make in particular,
where they are so focused
on being competent that they
forget to be warm, and so they
end up coming across as cold.
And then, cold and competent
is a particularly toxic brew
for trust.
By the way, just
to round it out--
I don't think anybody here
needs to worry about appearing
incompetent, but just in
case you're wondering,
incompetent and
warm would be Homer.
Towards people who are
incompetent but warm,
we tend to have pity and
compassion reactions.
And then if you're incompetent
and cold, you're Moe.
We tend to have
disgust reactions
toward people like that.
We don't really want to have
anything to do with them.
But for your purposes, what
you need to think about
is, do I want to be Lisa or
do I want to be Mr. Burns,
and how can I make sure that
I'm sending Lisa signals?
So here's how you do it.
It's not rocket
science, and it really
does just involve, again,
cultivating awareness
of what you're doing
and being deliberate
about the signals that you send.
So the first one is
maintain eye contact.
When we talk about
projecting competence,
we talk all the time
about the importance
of looking at people when
you're talking to them.
But that's actually not
the one I want you to do,
although you should
do that, too.
What I'm talking about
here is looking at people
when they're talking to you.
That's how you send
a warmth signal.
And more and more,
we're not doing it.
I love my smartwatch and my
smartphone and everything
just as much as anybody
else in this room.
But the presence of
these things in our lives
means that more and
more, we are not
looking at people when
they are talking to us.
And if I had a nickel
for every meeting
that I went to where eyes
are literally everywhere--
and you're looking at me now.
I feel really good.
You're all my friends.
But in regular meetings,
our eyes are everywhere.
And you might be listening.
You might totally be listening.
But you don't look
like you're listening.
And that sends a very strong
coldness signal to the speaker.
It looks like
you're uninterested.
It looks like you don't care.
It looks like
you're checked out.
So a very simple but very
powerful thing you can do
is actually track the person
who's speaking in the room,
and make sure they see you--
it's not enough to listen.
You have to look like
you're listening.
The next one is smile and
nod-- not like a crazy person,
but just a little bit more
maybe than you might normally.
Smiling is really
great, especially
if someone smiles at you.
Oh please, don't ever
let someone smile at you
and you don't smile back.
That's a super cold sign.
And then, nodding at the end of
sentences is really important.
This is one of
these things where,
if you're ever in a conversation
with someone who doesn't do it
and you feel super
uncomfortable and often you
can't put your finger on why,
but if somebody just sort
of stares back at you
while you're talking
and you can't really-- are
they following what I'm saying?
Do they know?
It's really disturbing.
So a little head nod
as someone's talking
is really important.
It lets them know-- it's like
a little mini affirmation,
like yes, I agree with you,
and I'm understanding--
super important.
Show empathy-- again, not like,
let's take out a box of Kleenex
and cry about
things, but just sort
of saying-- when something bad
happens to someone, saying "I'm
sorry that happened"
is what psychologists
call a superfluous apology.
It literally is, I
didn't do the bad thing,
but I'm sorry it
happened to you-- like,
oh, I'm sorry it rained on
you on your way to work,
or I'm sorry you have to deal
with this frustrating client
or whatever-- those
kinds of simple signs
that you're paying
attention to the fact
that someone's having
a difficult time,
and you're expressing
something about it--
very powerful way to express
empathy and to show warmth.
Trust them first-- human
beings are absurdly reciprocal.
I mean, we just give
back what we get.
And there is something very
powerful about trusting
people that makes them want
to trust you in return.
It's one of the reasons why
micromanaging is so toxic.
I mean, being micromanaged
is irritating.
But one of the other
things that it does
is it tends to undermine your
trust in the person who's
micromanaging you, because
they don't trust you obviously,
so why should you trust them?
So again, it's something
very important to think about
from a leadership position.
When you're in one,
trusting other people
or trusting the other people
on your team, your colleagues,
can make them want to
trust you in return.
And finally, be affirming-- I
know it's sort of a gross word,
but it is actually really
important-- not to make stuff
up.
I wouldn't ever suggest you say
anything that you don't mean.
But very, very often,
we think positive things
about the people in our lives,
about the people we work with,
and we just don't say them.
And there's this expression,
"it goes without saying."
That's a terrible expression.
It goes with saying.
All of this stuff
goes with saying.
If you don't say it, they
don't know you think it.
And so one thing I
think each of us can do,
really, is think about little
ways in which we can express
more the positive
things we're already
thinking about the people
we work with all the time.
It's a great way,
again, to show warmth
and to create that trust.
So all simple stuff,
but the trick here
is actually doing it,
and actually making
a point of doing it--
because much of the time,
we don't give as much thought to
this as we do to whether or not
I look smart and
capable and competent.
Two things I want to
mention, because this often
kind of comes up-- you do not
look less smart if you're warm.
This is one of these things like
people believing that there are
math people, as if some people
are just born good at math
and some people don't have the
genes to be able to do that.
And what are these
beliefs that undermine
a lot of people's behavior?
And this is another one--
people do implicitly
assume that the warmer they
are, the dumber they look,
and the colder they are,
the smarter they look.
In fact, there are
studies that show this.
If you bring people into a lab
and you say, write a letter.
And in the letter, I want
you to impress someone
with how intelligent
you are, they
bring out all of
their 25 cent words.
And if you say, I want
you to write a letter
and I want you to make the
person really like you,
they literally don't
use any words that
have more than six letters.
It's just insane.
We dumb down when
we want to be liked,
and we get cold when
we want to seem smart.
And the tradeoff is
completely unnecessary,
because it actually
isn't accurate.
Perception doesn't
work that way.
People don't think you are less
smart just because you're warm.
So again, be careful
of that, because you
see that a lot, where
people think they
have to seem tough
to seem smart.
And that's not the case.
The other thing is if you're
uncomfortable with the idea
of warmth because you're
just really not a fuzzy bunny
kind of person, that's OK.
There are lots of ways to
show warmth that are not
particularly mushy, like
being principled and being
fair, and being transparent
and being loyal.
All of these are ways of
showing warmth in that they
show that you're on
the other person's side
and you have good
intentions toward them,
without actually having to
pull out any Kleenex-- so lots
of ways to do it.
The key thing,
really, is to think
about doing it in a very
proactive and deliberate way.
And by the way, a
great place to start
is finding out whether
or not you actually
do any of this stuff.
So one of the
problems that happens
is-- I give talks on this all
the time, and people will say,
oh, I know that I
nod and smile a lot.
And then the person next to
them is going, no, they don't.
They don't actually
ever do that.
Because we all think
we do these things,
and then it turns
out that we don't.
So one thing I recommend-- I
really recommend doing this.
You sort of have to steel
yourself a little bit,
but I get great feedback
from people when they do it.
Find someone who's
worked with you
for at least a little while,
who knows you pretty well
and who you think you trust
to tell you the truth,
and ask them to
answer this question.
If I didn't know
you so well, I would
think that you were blank.
You hear all kinds of stuff when
you ask people this question.
If I didn't know
you so well, I'd
think that you were arrogant.
If I didn't know
you so well, I'd
think that you weren't very
bright, and so on and so on.
And don't get mad.
That's actually
really important.
Don't get angry with
them for telling you.
And then follow it up with, why?
And you find out.
People will tell you,
oh, it's because whenever
we're in meetings,
you never look
like you're paying attention.
You look like you
can't be bothered.
Or whenever we're
in meetings, you
twirl your hair on your
finger, and it's really weird.
And you find out, oh
my god, didn't even
know that I was doing that.
So it's very, very useful
as a starting place when
you think about what you need to
do in order to send more warmth
signals, or even more
competence signals,
to find out what signals
are you sending now
and to ask someone who
knows you better to say,
you do actually do a few things
that I think maybe give people
the wrong impression, and
here is what they are.
It's a great place to start.
Have a little courage,
and it totally pays off.
OK, being likable-- here's the
thing about colleagues working
together, is that
it's very easy--
and especially a
place like Google,
where you have a lot
of successful people,
a lot of
achievement-oriented people--
for one person on a team's
success to end up really,
really bothering the
people around them,
even if they don't
really realize it--
and often they don't.
Often it's not fully conscious
that the reason that I'm happy
right now is that
you're so successful,
but it happens all the time.
Psychologists call
this ego threat.
And it happens, once again,
as a function of two things.
And no, I'm not going to use
the same sentence this time--
it happens as a function
of two dimensions.
So we are threatened
as a function
of how relevant
someone's success is
to the success we want to have.
Are you successful at the thing
I want to be successful at?
And closeness-- and
closeness here is basically,
how much are you in my life?
Do I have to see
you all the time?
Am I constantly
reminded of the fact
that you are successful at this?
High threat occurs when these
two things are both high--
when you have someone who is
successful at the thing you
want to be successful
at, and you
have to see them all the time.
So again, sort of a famous
example, the Bush brothers
wanting literally the same
job, which not many people get,
and close by virtue
of the fact that they
are in the same family.
But interestingly,
this does seem
to have created a lot
of threat between them,
because they aren't
very close in the sense
that they don't hang out
together very much, as far as I
know-- so high threat.
And this happens
with siblings a lot.
When two siblings actually want
to be good at the same thing,
it can create a lot of
tension in a family.
Here's an interesting case,
and I'll come back to it.
It should also be the case
for the Williams sisters.
Serena and Venus
Williams should be
very threatened by one another.
They're very close,
and their successes
are very relevant
to one another.
But they're not.
And so I'll come back to
that one in a little bit.
A moderate threat
is created when
you have high relevance but
lower closeness-- so someone
is trying to be successful
at the same thing you are,
but you don't have to
see them all the time.
So here we have-- that is real.
That is not a
photoshopped photo.
He does that.
So you would think,
again, both sort
of wanting to be
leaders of the world,
but they probably can
go whole days at a time
without thinking
about one another.
So the threat is a
little bit lessened.
The ideal cell to be in is the
basking in the reflected glory
cell, which is you're
close to someone
but they're successful
in something
that is completely
irrelevant to you,
that you do not define
yourself at all.
And here's a fun piece
of trivia to whip out
at your next cocktail party.
Ira Glass and Philip
Glass are cousins.
And so they can
get together-- so
Ira Glass, the "This American
Life" host, Phillip Glass,
the composer-- are cousins.
So they can get
together and just
bask in how awesome
it is to be a Glass,
and just enjoy each
other's success,
and there is no threat there.
It's just terrific.
And then just to
sort around it out,
again, obviously if you have
no closeness or relevance,
there is no threat.
That one might be photoshopped,
but I love it so much.
I don't care.
[LAUGHTER]
Presumably they don't
threaten one another at all.
OK, so how do you deal with it?
So if you are in the
situation that a lot of people
are in the workplace,
where you're
working with people who
are doing very similar work
to your own, their successes
may be threatening to you,
or in this case, your successes
may be threatening to them.
How do people deal with that?
Well, a couple of ways-- you
can kind of think of the problem
as being you're too
close and too comparable.
You're like two apples.
So one solution is you
can decrease relevance.
One of you can become an orange.
This is actually what
many siblings do in order
to stop killing each
other-- most famously,
probably, the Emanuel brothers.
So one is a politician,
one is a doctor,
and one is a Hollywood agent.
Interestingly, when they
were all children-- and so
therefore, much
more comparable--
they basically beat each
other up every single day.
But now as adults, they
get along quite well
because they're very successful
in very different domains.
Another thing you can do is
try to decrease closeness.
You can try to just
literally get away
from the person who
is threatening you.
That's what these two
gentlemen did for years.
They basically tried to avoid
each other at all costs.
This is sort of later in life.
You can just see Bill
Gates' posture is
still like, I'm literally
trying to get as far
away from you as I
can in this chair,
because they had a
relationship that threatened
one another quite a bit.
OK, what if you can't do
either of those things?
Like most of you,
you're on a team.
You really can't
go be an orange,
and you can't really get away
from the people you work with.
So how do you deal with it?
Well, what most
people do when they
don't have any other
options left is
they just decide to basically
not like you anymore.
They find something
wrong with you.
That's how they
deal with the fact
that you're threatening
to them, is they decide,
you're not so great, and they
find some way to take you down
a notch.
And this is obviously
what we want to avoid.
This is the problem.
When your success threatens
the people around you,
they will find ways
to not like you
so that they can feel
better about the fact
that they're threatened.
And you can say that's
horrible and terrible,
but we all kind of do it.
And they don't realize
they're doing it,
so it's not really like
they're doing it on purpose.
So how do we avoid this problem?
You avoid this problem by
switching from my apple
is better than your apple to
we are the best damn basket
of apples around here.
You create a sense of us
so that one person's win
is a win for everyone.
And this is really,
really important,
and is incredibly
important in the workplace,
for teams to have
this sort of identity,
especially when there's a really
high likelihood that people
can threaten one
another in the team.
There's basically three really
effective ways to do this.
One is to create a
strong team identity.
You can do that
any number of ways.
I mean, the easiest way to do it
is to have a common enemy-- not
someone also in Google, please.
Please pick someone
outside the company
to have as your common enemy.
But a common enemy can
create, very easily,
a strong team identity.
But also, just sort of talking
about the team as a team a lot,
and talking about
your shared goals.
I tell managers all the
time that there really
shouldn't be a meeting that
gets started without talking
about what the goals
are for the team,
without talking about the
accomplishments of the team,
without talking about everything
in the context of a team.
And you have to do it
so much that you'll
start to think it's weird,
but it's actually not weird
because what you're doing
every single time you
do that is making that team
identity very accessible
for the people in the
room, and you're making it
more and more the way
they would typically
think about what they do.
To the extent that you can
incentivize them as a team,
that's a good thing.
But anything you can do to take
the focus off the individuals
in the team and really
celebrate the team as a whole
starts to deal
with this problem.
And then the last
bit is celebrating
other people's wins.
And this is something
each of us can do more of.
We can try to remove
some of the tension
by you taking the first step.
Again, human beings
are incredibly
reciprocal by nature.
If you go up to someone else
and celebrate the heck out
of their win and
say how great it is
and how proud you are
to be on their team,
because they're doing
so great, they're
going to be more likely
to do that back to you.
So you can defuse a
lot of the tension.
If you suspect that there
are people around you that
are a little bit
threatened by you,
the one way to
diffuse that tension
is to actually go and celebrate
them and make a big show of it.
And when you do
that, it actually
will help to create
the sense of us
and make it so
that when you win,
they're going to actually be
kind of excited about that,
and they can bask in
the reflected glory
of your awesomeness rather
than feel threatened by it.
So that's basically
actually what's
happened with the
Williams sisters.
If you read interviews with them
or know anything about them,
you find that the way they
talk about themselves is they
talk about themselves
as the Williams family.
And that really seems to be
the sort of primary identity
that they have.
So a win for any Williams is
a win for the Williams family.
They actually perform
usually at their worst
when they're playing
with one another,
because it's very hard
for them to process that.
But they love it when
the other one wins,
and they really feel
like it's their win.
And that's something
that actually any team
can accomplish if team
identity is something
that you really focus on.
So what's in it for you, if
you do all this extra work?
If you decide that
you're going to take
a little bit of extra time and
effort and send these signals,
what's in it for you?
A psychologist
named David Funder
has spent quite
a bit of his time
studying people who are
what he calls good targets.
Some of us are a little bit
more easily judged than others.
Some of us are
sending these signals
that help other people
to understand us
and to read our
intentions correctly.
And so he's studied
these good targets
to see how do their lives
different than people
who are not good targets.
And he's found a
number of things.
First of all, good targets
make better first impressions.
That turns out to be, as I
said, a really important thing.
If you're better
at sending signals,
you make the right first
impression from the get-go
rather than having to spend
a whole bunch of time undoing
the damage you've done.
Good targets have much more
satisfying relationships.
They report being much
happier in their relationships
that they're in.
Good targets enjoying
more social support,
both professionally
and personally.
They have more
people in their lives
who can help them when
they need help in order
to achieve the things
they want to achieve.
And finally, good targets have
consistently greater happiness
and well-being.
And these things seem
like good things, right?
This is definitely, I
think, worth thinking about,
how you can become
a better target.
I mean, it's up to you.
You have a choice.
You can either sort of sit back
and be unhappy that nobody ever
seems to understand you,
and just cry about it,
or you can take a little
bit of extra effort,
you can be a little
bit more strategic,
and you can really take
steps to bridge that gap--
and to finally,
much more reliably,
come across the way you
intend to with the people that
are important to you.
And so that is all.
So I will take questions with
whatever time we have left.
And there's a microphone.
So please use it,
or chaos will ensue.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I was just wondering how this
is involved with performers.
How would they want to display
their sort of performing
abilities or their image?
HEIDI GRANT
HALVORSON: Sort of you
want the audience to like you?
That kind of idea?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON: I
think that there again, it
boils down to trying to
send as many warmth signals
as possible.
So among speakers, you see
a lot of variety in this.
You see that some people
do actually make a point
of looking at the audience,
and some people don't.
Their eyes are
sort of everywhere.
I think simple
things, like looking
like you're actually speaking
to an actual person is helpful.
Humor is really good.
You always have to be a
little bit careful with humor.
You don't want to make
fun of other people.
That's not a great
way to be warm.
But making fun of
yourself a little bit,
or humor that is based on
sort of common problems,
like were-all-in-the-same-boat
kind of things.
That can be a really, I
think, great sign of warmth.
But I think anytime you can
create a situation where you're
feeling like you're having a
genuine connection with people
and they're actual individuals,
anything individuating
is sort of helpful--
that you're not just
treating it like a crowd.
Those things can be helpful.
It's a lot of the
same things, actually,
that you would just say
you should do to someone
you're talking to on
the street, right?
It's not that different.
It's a little more
challenging when
it's you talking to
a roomful of people,
but I think a lot of the
same signals can be sent.
And one of the
other challenges--
you just reminded me.
One of the other big
issues with sending warmth
is when-- face to
face interactions
is actually relatively easy.
But when you move
to either one person
talking to a whole roomful of
people or you move, even worse,
to phone conversations-- or
even worse than that, to email
conversations--
then you lose a lot
of ways in which human beings
show warmth to one another.
And it's funny.
I think we write
emails to people--
we speak to people
over email in ways
that we would never speak
to another human being face
to face.
You would never just
walk up to someone
and launch immediately into
what you want from them.
It would always begin with a
sort of, hey, how you doing?
Oh, last week I remember
you were working on x.
And I totally think
there's no reason
you can't start an
email just like that, as
if it is a conversation.
The tone feels very different.
But emails are consistent.
No one ever sent a warmer
email than they meant to.
It's always that it comes across
colder or more rude or more
distant, because we're missing
a lot of those ways in which we
send those cues.
Also, video-conferencing
is amazing.
And I always tell people
to go the extra mile.
I know it's a pain, but if
you can get face-to-face
in a meeting rather than
having people dial in,
you lose a lot of the risk
of a lot of those coldness
and other issues
that can creep in.
Thank you for the question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, howdy.
I want to go back to the
strong team identity.
You mentioned the easiest way,
or any easy way that people
do that, is by finding
a common enemy.
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does it have to
be a person or a group?
Could it be something like
the bugs that we have,
or just inefficiency in general?
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON: Yes.
Yes, because people love to
sort of anthropomorphize things.
So if you talk about a
thing like it's an enemy,
that works completely.
A particular problem-- we're
up against this problem.
We're going to win.
We're going to
beat this problem.
And you talk about it
like it's a person,
then you get the same
psychological mechanism
sort of kicking in.
What you're trying to
activate is-- our brains
are basically wired
to have very strong
ingroup-outgroup distinctions.
So we identify people as
either in-group or out-group,
and we operate in those terms.
And so you're trying, when
you mention team identity
and talk about all
of those things,
you're really trying
to kick that into gear
and have the brains of
everybody in the room
see one another as all in-group.
And you can do that with real
outgroup, like real enemies,
but you can actually
do it with anything
that threatens the people
who are in that group.
That works as well.
So yeah, and that's
actually a great way
to solve the problem, where
you don't have to actually have
an enemy team but you can
have the enemy be just about
anything.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: I had a
question on a similar line
to that with the whole
ego threat thing.
And it involves what
if it's a relationship
and the goals involved are a
more broad thing, like career
or salary success,
money-- things like that?
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON:
What's the relation--
AUDIENCE: It's like a
marriage, for instance.
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON:
Oh yeah, and you have
ego threat in the marriage?
AUDIENCE: Where one partner
is succeeding at a career,
succeeding in a
business-- something
like that-- where the
other partner struggles.
That seems like a--
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON: Yeah,
it's a huge problem, isn't it?
It is.
It's actually a huge,
huge, huge problem.
One of the reasons why--
it's a big problem regardless
of the genders of the
individuals involved.
However, traditionally,
it often seems
to be a larger problem for
men, in part because women--
it's not because
women are saints,
but because women have
more of a tendency
to see themselves as an "us."
So women just sort of--
again, this is an on-average.
Everybody is different.
But on average, women
have a greater tendency
to self-identify as an us
rather than as an individual.
And so therefore, when they have
a partner who is doing really
well, they can at least
have a better shot at doing
the bask-in-the-reflected-glory
part.
Men, who tend to be
more individualistic
and identify just
as an individual,
that tends to be more difficult.
But again, it can happen
with both genders.
It definitely is a
source of conflict.
And the answer is that you end
up diminishing closeness, often
through things like divorce
and choosing different partners
that don't threaten you.
So it is absolutely a problem.
I think the people
that deal with it
the best tend to be people
who have found a way
to make it an "us"
thing, to make
your success is my success.
But I always marvel
at couples who
seem to be doing the same
work and who can manage that,
because I think that the
potential for conflict
is so great there that it's
sort of amazing that they
can make it work.
Yeah.
And it happens in friendships.
You see in many instances,
friends drift apart
because one becomes
more successful
and that just becomes
a source of tension.
Absolutely.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because
I have a question, too.
You mentioned that nobody
sends an email warmer
than they expect it to be.
So at Google here, we have
hundreds of emails a day.
It's ridiculous.
And so personally,
I'm always in conflict
between trying to send
the shortest, quickest
email out the door to
be as direct as possible
while still balancing the
line between not coming across
as a total jerk.
Do you have any sort of
recommendation for the tone
of what the email should take?
Should I add more winky faces?
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON: I
mean, it's really interesting
to see emojis seeping into
more and more business
communication, because
they are needed, right?
They're Substituting
for the tonal qualities
that we don't have
in that format.
We need to know you're winking.
That's a joke.
So I think we're going to see
that happening more and more,
that more emojis become
a way we communicate.
It's funny, because
I was at a conference
talking about this with people
who were interested in doing
chat with customers online.
And they want those
conversations to be short.
But they can also be warm.
They don't have to be
lengthy, the warmth bits.
So literally, hey,
how you doing?
Literally, hey, how you doing is
a great way to start an email.
It's amazing how
often we don't even
bother to do that, that
we just go, Hi, Bob,
I need the such and such.
And so even just saying,
Hi, Bob, how are you doing,
hope you're good, I
need the such and such,
is much better email
than the other.
So you don't have to
completely sacrifice brevity.
Nobody also wants to read
epically long emails.
And the questions are not
meant to be answered, really.
There's those things
we do all the time when
we interact with other people.
We say, hey, how are you?
Good.
There's no information
exchanged there.
That's just a greeting
that humans have, right?
It's a little dance.
And so you need to kind of do
that dance in other formats
as well, because again, people
can't put their thumb on why
they're annoyed with you
about the email you just sent.
They won't know it's because
you didn't say hi, how are you,
but that's not helping.
So I think yeah, short
ways of being friendly
can be very powerful.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
HEIDI GRANT
HALVORSON: OK, great.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: One in the back.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked about how
we can help other people see
us the way we see ourselves.
I know that there's other psych
research out there about how
we see ourselves incorrectly.
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON: Yeah.
[CHUCKLES]
AUDIENCE: So in any
kind of conversation,
kind of like a
combative conversation
or a crucial conversation, what
do you think contributes more?
Is it that I see myself
differently from what we might
think of as reality, or that--
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON:
The gap, right?
How much of the gap is I don't
understand myself very well,
and how much of the
gap is the other person
does not understand me.
That's really a question.
And there isn't any
one answer to that,
except to say that they're
both big contributors.
And certainly, the more you
find that other people all
have the same opinion about
you but you're different,
that's where you start to
suspect maybe they're right
and you're wrong.
So certainly, part of the reason
the correlations aren't perfect
is that sometimes other
people do see things in us
that we don't see in ourselves.
I think you fix probably
more than 50% of the problem
if you start realizing that
you're doing a bunch of things
you don't mean to be doing.
I think most miscommunication
comes from that, not
from a lack of
self-understanding
about who you are and
what your intentions are,
but a lack of self-awareness
about how the behaviors you're
engaging in are being
perceived by other people.
When you have a
misunderstanding,
when you feel like
you didn't come
across the way you intended
to, your intentions
were good, right?
It's just that the
execution was flawed.
That's probably
more of the problem
than it is the I wasn't
really honest with myself
about what my intentions
were in the first place.
But of course, that
can be a problem too.
So self-awareness helps
for a couple of reasons.
It helps you to really
understand yourself,
but also helps you to
cultivate some sense of,
what is it that I'm doing and
how is that being perceived?
I focus on that in this book,
because I feel like, especially
in the workplace, that's
the bigger problem.
But we could all also do with
a big dose of self-awareness,
as well.
You're right to point out
that it's not all them.
Some of it's you.
So thank you.
One here, I think?
AUDIENCE: This will
be the last question.
We're out of time here.
AUDIENCE: So I've
found lately that a lot
of my issues with
interacting with other people
is not being able to find
relevant competence in others
related to things that I
identify with as unique to me.
So do you have any
advice for kind
of both sides of
it-- either avenues
towards finding that kind
of relevant competence
in other people, and
also incorporating
more of other
people's competence
to be more relevant to you?
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON:
So the competencies,
abilities, interests,
experience-- all those kind
of things-- how to
connect with people more,
how to find where the
overlap is maybe with yours?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, find the
happy medium so that you're--
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON:
Just a couple things
about that I would say.
One is that often, because we
are all also bad pereceivers--
so we have the problem of
being perceived incorrectly,
but we also all could
maybe be better perceivers.
And so very often, people
have competencies and things
like that that we sort of
assume that they don't have,
because we're not really
asking a lot of questions.
And by the way, it's
sort of a win-win,
because if you have more
curiosity toward other people
and you ask them more
questions, not only
do you get to find
out all the stuff,
but it's also a great
way to show warmth.
Being curious is wonderful.
People love being
asked about themselves.
It's like the best thing.
And people think you're smart
when you ask them questions
about themselves.
It's awesome.
So ask, I would
say, more questions,
because sometimes you might be
just assuming that something
isn't there that actually is.
And then the other thing
is a little bit more
of a growth mindset kind
of idea, where right now I
don't necessarily
understand what's
interesting about this
person's competencies.
I don't get why they do it.
But maybe if I ask
a bunch of questions
about why-- why do you
find this interesting?
Why do you see it-- why have you
done the things you're doing?
Maybe I'll learn some
stuff, or maybe there'll
be a connection there.
Maybe there's a parallel that
I haven't really picked up on.
So I think if you're kind of
a little bit more open-minded
and also do a lot
more questioning,
there's usually more
there than meets the eye,
especially if it's somebody
who happens to just not be
very forthcoming.
A lot of people
are kind of closed,
and they're not comfortable
with a lot of disclosure
and they don't say much.
But there's really a lot
going on if you probe.
And people, generally
speaking, like
to be asked questions
about themselves.
So it's usually welcome
when you do that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But I think the trouble
comes from where
to start with those questions.
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON:
Start anywhere.
I don't think there's
good advice for that.
I mean, I think you can
start with the common ground
that you share, which
is often the easiest
way to have a conversation, with
whatever you do know that you
even have in common, even if
it's superficial commonalities,
and then kind of dig
in deeper from there,
even asking questions
about why someone
made the choice they did or why
did you find that interesting.
The sort of
perspective questions
can open up a whole
bunch of possibilities.
There's no wrong way
to do it, I think.
AUDIENCE: It just
feels like there's
a huge gap between
superficialities
and below the surface.
HEIDI GRANT HALVORSON: You do,
you have to work to get there.
The first questions are
always sort of almost
by definition
superficial, because it's
almost weird to not.
It'd be almost weird to
dive into some really deep,
how do you think your
childhood impacted you?
That'd be weird.
And so you have to kind
of approach it gradually
with things that may
seem like small talk.
I don't love small
talk either, but a lot
of times the entryway into a
conversation or a friendship
is small talk that
becomes deeper talk as you
realize that you
have more things
in common or more perspectives.
There's interesting
research on the difference
between what's called
i-sharing and me-sharing.
So me sharing is when we
share things with one another.
We recognize that we have things
in common with another person
that are just
traits or, oh, we're
both from Des Moines, Iowa,
or oh, we both like computers.
Oh, we both do x.
But I-sharing is
perspective sharing.
So it's like, oh, I've
had the experience
of looking at a
sunset in New York,
and I just thought
it was amazing.
Oh, I've had that
experience, too.
So I sharing is that
experience sharing,
where we realize we have
the same perspective
as another person on something.
That actually is
the most rewarding
and creates the deepest
connections between people.
But a lot of times, conversation
starts out as me-sharing.
It starts out as,
what do you do?
Here's what I do.
Here's where I've lived.
Here's where you lived.
Oh, do you like soccer?
I like soccer, too.
And then it becomes
conversations
about deeper things.
But you kind of have to
get through that first part
to even know what
kinds of experiences
you might have in common.
So it takes patience,
and a lot of fishing.
OK, great.
Thank you all so much.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]